Welcome back everyone this will be my new
guardians of the galaxy 3 video all about
adam warlock thankfully marvel finally confirmed
what's going on with his character so we'll break
it all down there's a bunch of easter eggs
in the future of marvel phase 4 because he's
such a huge character obviously he's
going to continue past guardians 3.
if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos it's going to get
really crazy the rest of the year
with a bunch of really cool stuff
most of you probably saw the news yesterday that
will poulter has officially been cast as adam
warlock in the mcu for guardians of the galaxy 3
and like i said beyond that in other marvel movies
because he originally debuted in the fantastic
four comics i also expect there to be a connection
between what's happening with him in guardians of
the galaxy 3 and marvel's new fantastic four movie
james gunn himself confirmed the news with a
funny post about how he always loves dunking
on people and websites for fake scoops about his
movies and then just stops short like so i'll say
welcome to the guardians of the galaxy family will
poulter he's an amazing actor and a wonderful guy
the reason why he says see you in a couple weeks
here is because they're actually starting to film
the movie in a couple weeks finally starting to
film the movie after years and years of delays
the funny thing is he actually finished the script
for this back in like 2018 i think around avengers
infinity war territory but then he followed up
with another reply to another comment just hyping
up will poulter as being incredible they actually
said that they auditioned almost every major young
male actor in hollywood who was available for
adam warlock so if he beat out much bigger stars
he must have just blown james gunn away with his
performance so i would trust in his judgment when
it comes to casting because james gunn is pretty
picky when it comes to casting and he has done a
great job of casting all of his other movies will
poulter the actor wasn't someone who was even on
my radar though is adam warlock like everybody
had their fan casting for adam warlock because
he was such a huge character and we've known
about him coming to the mcu for a long time
most of you might remember the actor from black
mirror bandersnatch he was also in mid-summer
which also starred our new black widow elena
balova even if you haven't seen any of his
recent stuff which is actually pretty solid some
of you will at least remember him from a billion
years ago as that kid from chronicles of narnia
voyage to the dawn treader obviously he's grown
up quite a bit since then that was about 10 years
ago that that happened but i'll explain what's
going on with adam warlock's character what this
means what's going on with him after guardians 3
as well as what's going on with the thor love
and thunder guardians of the galaxy crossover
because the next place that most of the guardians
are showing up is at the beginning of thor love
and thunder as we've seen from all the scenes
they've released last year and for the most
part all of them have some minor costume upgrades
obviously big change for thor because he's not fat
thor anymore spent a lot of time since avengers
end game borrowing star-lord's bowflex and because
there's a big guardians crossover during thor love
and thunder i believe on the other side of that
they'd also plan to have thor show up in guardians
3. at least the way that vin diesel said that they
had originally planned things out because the
funny thing is that originally had guardians 3
not been delayed we would have watched that movie
before we watched thor love and thunder so they
kind of had to reverse the way that the crossovers
worked with thor and the guardians bethor would
probably just show up at the beginning of
guardians 3 for a short cameo scene and then the
guardians go off to continue the mission that they
started during that avengers endgame ending scene
to find the younger 2014 gamora who took off there
was also a funny deleted scene of her taking off
in avengers endgame too and everybody was bending
the knee to iron man just to pay honor to him
because this version of gamora had no idea who
iron man was so she was like why are these people
doing this peace i'm out of here and just kind
of yeets out but adam warlock hell yeah time
to freak out it's about time most of us saw the
easter egg for his cocoon in the thor the dark
world post credit scene with the collector and
assumed that they would be doing him eventually
now james gunn obviously changed that just a
little bit when he got to guardians of the galaxy
2's post-credits scene to be fair ayesha even
uttered the words adam just to be extra clear
as to what was happening in this scene is a minor
change to his comic book origin but the sovereign
all have the gold skin and the cocoon looks just
like a mechanical version of his cocoon in the
comics so we just all held our breath just waiting
for them to announce guardians of the galaxy 3 and
had it not been delayed we actually would have
watched that movie summer of 2020 last year
adam warlock is one of the most powerful
characters in marvel comics he's the keeper
of the soul stone during the thanos infinity
gauntlet storyline he was originally created to
be kind of like this david bowie space jesus type
of figure and because we have the loki series now
with the kang multiverse war in the whole idea of
the marvel characters all having many variants of
themselves in other universes he's also got an
evil persona called the mages so in the mcu i
guess you would call the mages a variant of adam
warlock but at various points in the comics he's
been both a great ally to the guardians of the
galaxy the avengers the heroes but also a villain
to them through his mages persona he even straight
up joined one of the later guardians of the galaxy
rosters himself after the annihilation conquest
storyline and that was the storyline that served
as the basis for the mcu guardians roster the
one with rocket groot peter quill gamora drax
mantis so i know a lot of you are now also asking
what's going to happen with the guardians of the
galaxy team after guardians 3 because james gunn
has been saying that this is the last marvel movie
with this particular roster of the team so some
of the characters will either die or straight
up leave the team and some will continue on they
could always wind up doing guardians 4 but james
gunn said that it probably would not be him doing
guardians for it'll be some other director coming
in to take over the franchise but just like his
comic book origin story adam warlock has been
created as the perfect being to become the weapon
of the sovereign here in ayesha the minor change
here is that in the comics it was a group called
the enclave that created him to be their weapon
but same basic concept and just like his comic
book story we're all kind of expecting him to
rebel against his creators and eventually become
an ally to the guardians of the galaxy and other
marvel characters that he would cross over with
in future marvel movies also no coincidence when
he debuted in the comics some of his earliest
adventures were with thor it just so happens
that we have a big thor guardians of the galaxy
crossover coming up so funny how that works out he
didn't actually get the name adam warlock until he
went back into the cocoon and was reborn anew the
high evolutionary is the one that actually gave
him that name and gave him the soul stone before
the big thanos infinity gauntlet saga and speaking
of the high evolutionary there have been a lot of
theories that he's going to be one of the villains
of guardians 3 and that they'll just canonize him
as the person who created rocket raccoon there
was a minor easter egg for him in guardians of the
galaxy too when they traveled to berhert berhert
is an anagram of herbert as in herbert edgar
wyndham he was a normal human before he became the
high evolutionary james gunn teased ego the living
planet using easter eggs in the first guardians of
the galaxy movie foreshadowing that he'd be one of
the villains of the second movie which is why
there's the theory that high evolutionary could
be one of the antagonists of guardians 3. the
only other minor change that i'm expecting is
that there'll be some funny moment where someone
gives him the warlock part of his name like he'll
come out of the cocoon already being called
adam because ayesha already called him adam
but who's the person who winds up giving him the
warlock part of his name she's creating him for
the express purpose of destroying the guardians of
the galaxy but that's just where the story picks
up with him the basic idea being that he finishes
hashing out of the cocoon at the beginning of the
movie and the guardians of the galaxy will
have just finished their mini crossover
adventure with a newly buffed up thor during
thor love and thunder with gore the godbutcher
so the guardians will kind of be in recovery mode
licking their wounds metaphorically and then their
hit bam with one of the most powerful new marvel
characters in the universe but here's the thing
with adam warlock flipping from good to evil in
the comics some of you may have already seen this
coming too just kind of foreshadowed in the way
some other marvel characters arcs have played out
he's created to be a perfect being so his origin
story plays out a lot like the vision in the mcu
ultron hatch's vision like creates him in a cocoon
so to speak kind of is this perfect vessel for him
but instead he winds up being born with his
perfect body in half ultron programming half
jarvis programming so he's a complete open book in
terms of which way he could go either good or evil
but because he's so fresh out of his cocoon and
because his intelligence is so vast he takes the
more philosophical approach to the avengers so i'm
expecting a similar type of arc with adam warlock
if he's perfect he would eventually come to the
same conclusion therefore he'd stop trying to kill
the guardians of the galaxy because as it stands
if he wanted he'd be able to mow them down without
blinking at eye that's how powerful he is it's the
same thing with vision during avengers infinity
war he has an infinity stone in his forehead he
could have destroyed the avengers if he really
wanted to as we saw with the what-if episodes
with the version of ultron who actually took
vision's body but if you've been paying attention
to all the stuff james gunn has been saying about
guardians of the galaxy 3 the movie is actually
really all about nebula and gamora's story
it's kind of the same arc from guardians 2 only
this time it's flipped it's nebula who's trying to
save the more evil version of gamora as opposed
to gamora trying to save her sister so their
relationship is central to the story of the movie
yes peter quill does want to get her back because
he's still in love with her but really she's
not his gamora she's a totally different version
of the character because she came from 2014 long
before she ever met him there's also all the stuff
with rocket and groot's arc across the marvel
movies and groot finally growing himself back
up to full adult status vin diesel called him
alpha groot like the final boss form of groot
so i'm assuming when they show up during thor love
and thunder he'll still be the teenage version of
groot and they'll say that transformation
for some big moment in guardians 3 where he
becomes alpha groot we won't actually get the
first trailer for guardians 3 until next year
but we'll get some easter eggs and thor love and
thunder and some references to guardians 3 maybe
a post-credits scene teasing what's happening at
the beginning of the movie like early theory maybe
adam wore like hatches out of his cocoon in one
of the thor love and thunder post credit scenes
post all your theories do you actually think that
they'll save all the adam warlock stuff for the
actual movie or do you think they'll tease him in
a thor post-credits scene just to hype him up even
more so at least one of the post-credits scenes
will probably be guardians 3 related because
they are such a big part of thor love and thunder
everyone click here for that brand new eternals
trailer video in easter eggs and click here for
my what if episode 9 post credit scene video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one you!